Johnny Manziel Heisman Trophy winner
former Browns QB and former CFL and AAF
quarterback did we get the John Manziel
jersey yet Pauling oh I don't I haven't
seen it I show up and back out John I
thought we were getting the aaf Jersey
to hang up here in the man cave
I believe it's lost in transition but
you don't have to double back around and
then get that to you ASAP my apologies
okay you know we s we'll settle for an
XFL Jersey but I gotta wait for that too
yeah I guess we all have to kind of wait
oh what's happened to moving forward
okay
the XFL game plan you get reunited with
June Jones who coached you in the CFL
where do we stand with that with the
possibility of playing for XFL in
Houston yeah I don't know if what I said
the other day was all that bunch of
groundbreaking news that you know I
really looking forward to you know
continuing my football career wherever
that is no whether it's in the XFL
whether it's somewhere else whatever it
is and whatever it may be I just want to
keep a ball on my hand I just want to
keep going and keep playing football so
you know wherever that is whatever the
opportunities are the present itself
moving forward I'm just trying to do one
thing you know keep my head down stay in
shape and just and just keep going in
every aspect any chance to go to an NFL
training camp of you or your agent heard
from anybody I've had my head down you
know if he hasn't called me and said
anything then you know I leave
everything up to him in that regard
yeah I think in the past you know I let
it get to be and worried about it all
the time and kind of stressed over it a
little bit now it's just hey whatever
opportunities are gonna come your way
you know make the most of every single
one and you know keep doing the right
thing and good things will happen
how different are you if you are at all
from your days at a.m. to now in just
how you play football so physically and
how you play the position how much
different um you know I don't know I was
obviously a lot younger than you know
and then I think you may you know over
time you know injuries things like that
I've been lucky to be healthy so you
know I still feel like I have a lot left
in the tank you know I don't know if
it's exactly what it was when I was you
know 17 or 18 years old and a.m. but you
know I feel good my body feels great I
still
a lot of zip on the ball and I feel like
I'm doing it really good right now so
you know I'm in good shape I feel like
I'm going in the right direction
who do you work out with now you know I
still work out with George Whitefield in
San Diego and then you know I have it I
have a good base of people that I've
kind of acquired you know over the over
the couple years that good Regiment good
schedule and really you know for the
last couple years it's almost been
year-round just training and trying to
get back to the opportunities that I've
had
do you know what you're gonna do after
football whenever that happens you know
it's a little bit of an undecided you
know I've started working on a couple of
things I think may interest me and and
one thing that procurements means is
being back around you know it's like
saying em and whatever capacity that is
so now I have a good relationship with
Jimbo Fisher a good relationship with
the school and that's a place that means
a lot to me in a place that I want to
you know tie myself to for you know for
the long-term moving forward after my
football career will be over
have you talked to Jimbo about being a
quarterbacks coach or joining a football
staff early on I got to that point yet
but I do get a chance to go back to
College Station and I'll make sure I do
a couple things one that I go say hello
to Jimbo and two I just kind of popped
in there and go watch film being around
the program be around the guys have a
good relationship with kelan bond a guy
who I think is gonna have a breakout
year and has a ton of potential and just
trying to help them learn from you know
the guys in the QB room learn from some
of the things that I went through some
of the things that I struggle with in
college that you know I wish I had a
chance to go back and do a little bit
differently so you know I have a good
relationship with everybody and am I not
on that football building and you know
especially with what the quarterback
there right now now you know your fan of
the Browns you know I'm happy for all
the guys that are there you know I
wouldn't say I'm a fan of really in any
team in the NFL anymore out to have it
played and been in the business but you
know guys like Odell guys like Baker
Jarvis you know I know these guys and
I'm definitely global what about paying
college players I wondered about this
when we were having you on you and Tebow
and you know there's certain players
that
they they they're generating their their
income they're like you guys are
different but could you come up with an
ideal plan to pay college athletes or
those whose likeness is used I thought
about this a lot
I just don't understand every you know
the Alabama's of the world these big
schools having the you know unlimited
funds to be able to go do this type of
things this year in and year out a team
like that trumps you know a UCF Trump's
a smaller school how is that you know
competitive balance really shifted
whenever the money gets involved so I
think one day maybe down the road
they'll find ways for maybe a likeness
or you know things like that where guys
can capitalize a little bit but you know
the thing that we know about the NCAA is
I'm sure it'll be it'll it'll be
extremely light and I'm sure it'll be
you know unfair to the players
nevertheless if they're getting paid or
not what was your best offer coming out
of high school you know but you know
what I mean by all coming out was
probably our best offer like that and I
wasn't one of those guys yeah I was I
was a little you know five foot ten
quarterback for the middle of nowhere in
Kerrville Texas I was just happy to get
a scholarship offer from from anywhere
what's the best offer you heard that
somebody got I heard a couple guys got a
couple briefcases with some cash there
but definitely I wasn't on that at that
scale coming out of high school but you
know it was definitely there it's
definitely is relevant and definitely
alive it's college sports still to this
day it was a couple of months ago we had
John and you made news you said you were
gonna be known you wanted to be known as
John Manziel are you back to Johnny
Manziel what was the reaction you got
because it seemed like everybody picked
up on that story that all of a sudden
you were John Manziel that you were this
different person oh absolutely it was
definitely you know everywhere that I
went for the next four or five days
people would come up to me and apologize
to me for calling me Johnny and and it's
talking about four or five days for it
to get really really old being gone I
transitioned back very very quickly so
you're back officially to Johnny man
Szell one of the two I'm somewhere in
there but yeah Johnny Johnny fits me a
lot better John did for sure especially
out when I was there at it oh man
what do you miss most about playing I
just missed the competition that was the
best part about getting to the AAF was
just getting out there and I felt like
the competition level was good I felt
like I was getting better weekend and we
got out there being there you know only
two or three weeks but I just missed
getting a chance to compete and you know
if you don't stay on it every single day
and create you know a schedule for
yourself
that's similar to a workday whenever
you're not on a team and whatever you
don't have the you know schedule being
part of a team you know you can you can
slip a little bit here and there and I
think that's the biggest part for me is
making sure I keep myself busy and and
trying to add whatever competitive
balance whatever you know competitive
edge I can still get without being you
know in the NFL I know you can look back
now and maybe with the sense of humor
but how difficult were you to coach in
college you know I don't think I was
very difficult to coach in college yeah
I feel like I got along very very well
with my two offensive coordinators that
I had I still have really good
relationships with them to this day
College was was absolutely a tie my ways
are focused on how good can we really
get with this football and the guys that
we have you know at Texas A&M so but off
the field though you weren't you weren't
tough to reel in unlike did you give
coaches headaches off the field oh I
probably caused a little sleep was nice
for a for Coach some a little bit here
and there but the thing that you know my
mindset in college that probably got me
and a little bit of trouble was you know
I'm a college kid going out doing what
every other kid in America is doing on a
you know Thursday or Friday Friday night
whatever whatever it was and you know I
didn't see anything wrong with that and
at the time I wasn't going to apologize
for that whatsoever and when you get you
know into a professional setting or
whatever I decided to you know obviously
go pro that all has to change you have
you have a responsibility you know to
owners you're a brand it's completely
different and you know I think I held on
to that a little bit too long and should
have probably changed my ways a little
bit but at the time
I was I was living my best life and
college playing football in the SEC and
having the time of my life and I'll
never apologize to anybody for that you
had one of the great seasons in the
history of the sport at that position
like running and passing you lead the
SEC in rushing like that's mind boggling
for a guy who wasn't that highly
recruited how do you how do you process
you know having that kind of success
yeah I mean I look at the guys that I
have with me when I was at A&M you know
you look at our old line for you know of
the five guys that we had played in the
NFL as good as you could get Luke Joe
Cole Jake Matthews
you know Cedric abour a you look outside
you have Mike Evans uh number seven
overall pick yeah we were talented and I
got a lot of help and I think there was
a lot of hard work from a redshirt year
coming into the next year and having a
lot to prove you know I definitely had a
chip on my shoulder I think everybody
saw on Saturdays the way I played I
played hard as hell and I went out and
gave everything I had and I think I got
a lot of help from my teammates I think
I was in a great situation I had an
amazing coach including Larry and coming
someone and you know it was just it was
a special year for A&M especially here
personally but you look at the guys we
had on my team I don't think there's any
surprise that you know we that we did
what we did but how much enjoyment did
you take on beating or playing well
against Saban yeah if you didn't think
it was amazing to walk into the college
football awards at the end of the year
and shake coach sabers hand after
walking in Alabama and handed them a
loss and absolutely felt good but you
know I probably felt a little better for
him was going to that CC chambers to the
national championship and stomping Notre
Dame so I would have I would have traded
the you know the Windsor for being in
that position any day of the week but it
was a hell of a day in Tuscaloosa are
you when are you eligible for the
College Football Hall of Fame
the abbé to be out a certain number of
years I believe it's 10 okay hey you can
work on your speech there in the
meantime while you wait to hear from the
XFL right I guess I guess I got some
time on my hands here yeah you and Tebow
maybe you and Tebow can go in at the
same time close that'd be nice you're
performing but close yeah that'd be good
hey
stay in touch good luck with this and
thank you again Johnny absolutely thank
you for having me on it's always a
pleasure buddy
that's a Johnny Manziel guess no longer
John he's back - Johnny Manziel had a
good run is John Manziel for more Dan
Patrick show tune in the audience
channel 239 on DirecTV stream for free
on BR live or download the Dan Patrick
show at
[Music]